We have a ton of legislative news to dig into
today.
We'll be talking about the Equality Act.
We will be talking about covid relief.
But before talking about any of that massive
news late last night, the House of Representatives,
thanks to Democrats mostly this was this was
Democrats who voted for this.
Democrats in the House have passed the massive
voting rights and anti-corruption bill.
H.R. one Democratic Congressman Rokan to talk
to us about this when we interviewed him last
week.
And this is not the first time that H.R. one
has passed in the House.
It's the second time that it has passed, just
like the first time it passed.
It's not clear how it passes the Senate and
we'll talk about that.
But this is an extensive bill, 800 pages,
all sorts of different things contained within
it.
But the big items are a national system for
automatic voter registration.
This is something I've been talking about
for a decade.
It's something that would dramatically increase
participation in elections.
And it would ask right now you have to opt
in if you want to register to vote.
The default is if you do nothing, you're not
registered.
You have to opt in.
The system proposed in H.R. one would create
an automatic voter registration system where
you have to opt out if you don't want to be
registered to vote.
And why would you do that?
If you don't want to vote, you just wouldn't
vote and most people would just remain registered.
The bill would require every state to put
online options for voter registration, correcting
your voter registration, canceling or designating
a party affiliation, things that in other
countries are just obvious that you have any
developed country should have these things.
The bill would require at least 15 consecutive
days of early voting for federal elections,
and early voting sites would have to be open
for at least 10 hours a day.
This would short circuit and preempt many
of the state level voter suppression tactics
that Republicans have been using for a long
time.
And the bill would also ban states from restricting
someone's ability to vote by mail.
And it will also require states to prepay
postage on return envelopes for mail in voting
so it doesn't cost people money to vote by
mail.
The bill would ban voter roll purges and also
would ban the use of non forward able mail
as a way to remove voters from rolls.
Every one of these elements goes directly
at a technique used by the right to suppress
the vote.
And very interestingly, H.R. one establishes
a public financing of campaigns with small
donations.
The federal government would do a voluntary
six to one match for candidates for president
and Congress, which means every dollar a candidate
raises from small donors.
The federal government would match six times
over, and the maximum small donation that
would be matched is capped at two hundred
dollars.
It's not funded by taxpayer dollars.
The money comes from a four point seventy
five percent fee on criminal and civil fines,
fees, penalties and settlements with banks
and corporations that do corporate malfeasance.
Very interesting way to structure and finance
this.
And it also contains and again, we can't possibly
cover every line, but there are transparency
requirements for political advertising.
In H.R. one, it would establish nonpartisan
redistricting commissions to end partizan
gerrymandering.
Massive issue.
Again, we've been talking about it for a decade.
It would require presidential and vice presidential
candidates to disclose 10 years of tax returns.
And we know directly what that's related to.
It would stop members of Congress from using
taxpayer money to settle sexual harassment
or discrimination cases and so many other
things.
Now, beautiful bill has passed the House.
How does it pass the Senate?
And the answer is it doesn't unless it's modified
significantly.
But maybe something can pass.
The question is why Democrats control the
Senate.
Democrats voted for this in the House.
Why can't Democrats pass it?
The answer is there are just too many moderates
in the Democratic Party, in the Senate, and
the majority is too slim.
In fact, it's the slimmest possible majority.
The Senate is 50/50 Democrats, Republicans
because Democrats are in the White House.
Kamala Harris becomes the tie breaking vote
in the Senate when there is a 50 50 tie.
But this requires 60 votes to pass the Senate.
So, in other words, I'm unsure that if it
only required 50, it would pass the Senate,
but they need 60 votes anyway.
Now, one idea that Democrats are thinking
about is amending.
The Senate filibuster rules so that any democracy
reform legislation like H.R. one could pass
with a simple majority instead of 60 votes
now.
That's great if Joe Manchin goes for it.
And that's very much unclear if Jeanne Shaheen
goes for it.
I don't know if this is a bill that Jeanne
Shaheen is interested in passing.
So right now, the situation anyway is you
need 60 votes.
Now, this is an issue on which there is almost
no overlap between Democrats and Republicans.
We talk on this program.
You know, some shows love to take these black
white positions like there's no relevant difference
between Democrats and Republicans.
And the truth is that on some issues, there's
no relevant difference between Democrats and
Republicans.
And on other issues, they couldn't be more
different.
Democrats, at least in the House, are passing
H.R. one, which is a massive expansion in
voting rights.
It would permanently cement many temporary
expansions on the basis of coronavirus.
That's Democrats, at least in the House.
On the other hand, as we talked about on I
think it was Monday, Republicans have more
than 250 bills in 43 different states to suppress
the vote to make it more difficult to vote.
So these are diametrically opposed priorities
on these issues between Democrats and Republicans,
Democrats doing everything they can to increase
participation in elections, Republicans doing
everything they can to decrease participation.
Now, you can take a cynical view and say,
well, both sides are doing what they think
is best for them, for them.
Democrats believe more people voting is good
for Democrats.
Republicans believe fewer people voting is
good for Republicans.
They are both probably correct.
The difference is one of them is actually
in line with the principles and values that
this country is based on, which is not disenfranchizing
people giving people a voice, not putting,
not obstructing the ability of people to participate
in the democratic process.
It's hard to argue that the country is based
on the values that are exhibited by two hundred
and fifty Republican bills in 43 states to
suppress the vote.
So, yeah, sure, you can take the view that
it's quite simple and it's Democrats want
more people to vote.
So they when Republicans want fewer people
to vote, so they win.
One of those perspectives happens to be in
line with the foundation of this country.
Now, as a very practical matter, in the immediate,
Republicans have a particularly pressing reason
to oppose H.R. one, which is that they're
winning the House back in twenty twenty two
could depend on whether something like H.R.
one passes or doesn't pass.
And we'll talk more about that in the future.
That's H.R. one.
Let's now talk about covid stimulus